bonjour à vous pierre picard merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france donc c'est un entretien entre
vladimir poutine et tu jean ping qui
intervient moins de deux semaines après
la rencontre entre les présidents
américain et russe c'est un hasard de
calendrier selon vous alors pas de
calendrier puisque en fait depuis vingt
ans la chine y la fédération de russie
ont signé un pacte d'amitié us qui était
une marche nouvelles et importantes
après disons le le fait que la chine est
l'ex urss entendait beaucoup moins bien
donc c'est un partenariat important
parce qu'il permet de sceller la paix
mais également une coopération dans
cette partie de la vie et du lorientais
et qui assure également en même temps
une certaine stabilité des frontières
débit et du des échanges commerciaux
il est certain qu'il ya actuellement
faut le moins une concurrence en tout
cas la chine et la russie peuvent être
mis dans le temps le viseur des états
unis on est là un petit peu dans une
logique occidentale qui a toujours tendu
à à nous faire affronter ou confrontés
eux deux blocs finalement ne ne voulait
pas du tout et ne veulent pas se poser m
donc je ne crois pas c'est vraiment le
hasard du calendrier qui fait que
aujourd'hui la chine et la russie
réaffirmé leur amitié leur coopération
pour cohabiter ensemble avec des
politiques pacifiques au niveau
international c'est mon panier mais
parce qu'on sait aussi on connaît les
craintes de joe biden de voir à la
russie basculer définitivement dans le
giron de
de la chine oui vous savez on aurait pu
dire la même chose pour d'autres pays à
d'autres époques qu'il y en aurait pu
dire également que la que la chine
aurait pu basculer avec notre époque
dans les girons de l'ex urss mais tout
cela n'a aucun sens les dés la science
on est grande et belle nation que nous
avons également une eau grande et belle
nation et nos blocs à l'ouest il faut
éviter de devoir les confrontations et
surtout essayer de rassurer les choses
et puis de ne pas jouer trop sur la
confrontation sur la peur avec la russie
la chine mais plutôt essayer de
collaborer avec eux nous serons
concurrents mais de collaborer
je dirais avec des bonnes manières alors
la chine et la russie deux pays
émergents qui collabore en recettes déjà
dans le cadre des brics et selon un
communiqué donc l annonce officiellement
la prolongation du traité de bon
voisinage et de coopération amicale
comment vous l'interprétez qu'est ce
qu'il veut dire en fait qu'on a une
diplomatie finalement russes et
chinoises qui sont respectivement
instable il est même d'ailleurs on
pourrait même dire que les états unis et
l'union européenne ont également des
politiques et diplomatiques stable ça
veut dire en fait que la chine et la
fédération de russie ont pour objectif
de laisser je dirais le monde se dirige
est uniquement par l'ugta vie l'union
européenne ce qui fait en sorte une
forme de compétition internationale dans
différents domaines économique financier
et autres et c'est vrai que cela attire
bon nombre d'autres pays donc il ya
comme ça dans le pré carré des des
grandes nations qui ont le pouvoir des
rivalités pour qui fera quoi et et qui
donnera un petit peu le tempo
c'est en ces sens où aujourd'hui on a
deux nations qui pour autant sont fort
différentes et qui ont été en
compétition voire en guerre auparavant
mais qui aujourd'hui sans ils ont traité
le mot est bien signifiant un traité
d'amitié et de coopération pour assurer
la stabilité et puis la prospérité
économique
donc moi je vois cela de d'abonnés alors
prospérité économique ont fait que la
chine est fortement dépendante
l'étranger en ce qui concerne les
matières premières investit massivement
sur le continent africain d'ailleurs ce
que peut apporter la russie justement à
la chiné et vice versa aussi j'aurais
tendance à vous dire mais c'est pas le
sujet qu'on est tous interdépendants les
uns les autres dans tous les domaines de
l'énergie du pétrole et bien entendu la
première économie mondiale qui elle même
avec une croissance qui est maintenant
beaucoup plus durable néanmoins a besoin
de ressources énergétiques qui viennent
notamment de la fédération de russie
alors c'est justement dans le cadre de
ces négociations de ces partenariats
d'amitié tuchan signer d'autres pacte
qui vont intéresser la fédération de
russie notamment les nouvelles routes de
la soie le développement
d'infrastructures de voies ferrées de
chemin de fer pour faire justement ce
que la chine appelle des partenariats
gagnant-gagnant et non pas les
partenariats où chacun va essayer de
tirer la couverture à soi et sur le plan
géopolitique
quel sens donner justement à cette
alliance si on peut dire ainsi entre
rousseau si nos récents sont pas des
grandes embrassades mais c'est vraiment
une coopération amicale et e
je dirais économique qui se dessine avec
de pouvoir qui sont stables de deux
grandes nations de grandes cultures et
keith normalement devraient pouvoir
travailler uniquement d'ailleurs avec
l'union européenne et l'italie mais
également qui souhaite travailler avec
l'ensemble des pays du monde et du sud
et les plus pauvres les pays en voie de
développement
et c'est ça aujourd'hui le véritable
objectif c'est d'avoir une coopération
internationale qui ne se fonde pas
uniquement si bien uniquement sur nos
intérêts parce que nous avons un intérêt
les chinois les russes les américains et
c'est une belle chose mais il faut
maintenant que nous construisions un
petit peu ce que souhaitent les chinois
ce qui est également mon point de vue
c'est à dire en fait une zone planète
solidaire pour l'environnement pour le
progrès que les mic
on l'a vu avec le co vide pour lutter
contre différents virus et les maladies
donc maintenant il faut que chacun doit
prendre ses marques et aussi essayer de
travailler ensemble pour construire une
planète payeur et un mois meilleurs
merci beaucoup avant fierté car je
rappelle que vous êtes un géopolitologue
et spécialiste de la chine